no gavel This is Gonna Hurt
welcome to the wow organizational
meeting of the house committee on
Election law please rise and join me in
indivisible
all right so what we're gonna do here is
identify ourselves
so we know who we are because we're
going to be working together for two
years and then have a presentation from
the Secretary of State we will also be
working with for the next two years so
let's start down there and just
introduce yourself tell us where you're
from hi I'm Angela Brennan I am from
Beau and I'm representing Mary Mack 9
hi I'm Bob worry and I'm from Hillsboro
District 13 which is in Hudson
I'm Catherine Prudhomme O'Brien and I am
from Derry
foreign
I'm Connie Lane and I'm from here in
Concord Ward 2.
I'm Jessica Grill I'm from Hillsboro 18
Manchester Ward 12.
she's also our committee clerk I'm
Representative Steve Smith Sullivan
County District 3 Newport unity and
Charlestown
hi Jerry Ward Portsmouth Ward 4
Ralph boom litfield this is me my eighth
term and my second term on Election law
Heidi Hamer Manchester Ward 10
hello Jim qualey from Rindge I represent
Cheshire 18 which is Rindge Jeffrey in
Dublin's my second term in my second
Steve Kennedy Hudson Hillsboro 13.
Heath Howard Stratford 4 Stratford and
Barrington
Clayton Wood versus Sierra on on the
executive house and Pittsfield
foreign
ographical coverage that's always nice
all right Mr secretary thank you for
coming
oh and somebody else says there's no
pink cards today we're not justifying
just happy to have you here
okay well thank you Mr chairman and
members of the committee
uh I'm David Scanlon Secretary of State
uh I live in Beau and I'm happy to see
my state representative who's here on
this committee
um before I get started I would like to
introduce the team in the Secretary of
State's office and emphasize again that
it's a bipartisan team uh sitting next
to me is Aaron Hennessey the
Constitutional Deputy in the office and
behind her is Patty Lovejoy who's the
senior deputy
both Aaron and Patty have legislative
experience
Aaron has served in the Senate Anna
house Patty in the house both have
served on the finance committee and both
have accounting backgrounds which is
really helpful to the department
um and then sitting next to Patty a
couple seats over is Dave Lang my chief
of staff and I'll introduce Ann Edwards
too from the Attorney General's office
who we work very very closely with we
have an excellent working relationship
and while we administer the election
laws the AG's office enforces them and
um and it's great to see
familiar faces on the committee and it's
nice to see new faces and I look forward
to meeting those of you that you know we
haven't gotten
to meet yet
our office is open we have an open door
policy so you know if you want to come
in and talk about election related
issues you're more than welcome just
walk in and if we're not on the phone or
speaking with somebody we'll be happy to
sit down with you and have that
conversation
the Department of State is actually a
pretty good sized state agency we do a
lot more than just elections and I think
it's important for the committee to
understand that
leading off our administrative offices
of course are in on the second floor of
the State House room 204 just down the
hall from The Andy room on reps Hall
um you're welcome to come in there
anytime like I said we usually have a
candy dish on the table that's full so
if you need a little
you know a little energy that's a good
place to go and get it
um
in that office we receive many of the
filings that are required by Statute
um
everything from justices of the piece
and notary applications to obtaining
apostills
which are a certification of notaries
that are signing documents usually for
foreign countries mostly related to
adoptions and things like that
uh we cater to the governor and Council
we're in attendance at all of their
meetings taking the minutes
and so we handle a lot of their needs as
we have a corporations division which
which registers all business entities in
the state of New Hampshire
they're located in the annex we take up
probably 75 percent of the third floor
in that building and we also have the
Bureau of Securities which regulates
dealer Brokers those people that sell
financial instruments and they also are
responsible for some enforcement
activity in fact it's the enforcement
activity and the fines that they receive
that actually fund the operation
Securities collects probably 40 million
dollars
uh in uh in registration fees and all of
that money goes directly to the general
fund so it's a major uh Revenue
generator in the state of New Hampshire
up on the state hospital grounds the the
governor Gallen Office Park is located
the state archives and in that building
is housed the archives and Records
management division
um
you know we manage agency records that
are in the process of becoming dormant
they're no longer needed by the agency
but if they are we'll retrieve those
records for the agency and make sure
that they get them and then retrieve
them whenever they're done
uh we also have some of the state's most
historical precious documents up there
including the ratification document
which actually made the United States
the United States
um a tremendous amount of civil war
records revolutionary war records I
think the oldest document we have dates
back to the 1630s
and so it's a it's a fascinating place
um
Vital Records I mentioned we keep track
of marriages deaths births
and a lot of those
uh just statistical records that we
share primarily with the Department of
Health and Human Services and uh that's
also an important division within the
office
and then finally uh we have a
significant part of our elections
division up there we'll refer to it
often as the Hava office
stands for the help America vote act
which was passed in 2002
and that act requires us to uh required
us to create and maintain a centralized
voter database of all voters in the
state of New Hampshire
it required that we have accessible
voting equipment in every polling place
in the state of New Hampshire
it requires that we conduct poll worker
training it requires that we educate
voters on elections and election laws
and there's also a provision in there to
fund the enforcement activity that the
Attorney General's office May engage
related to enforcement of the help
America vote act in the state of New
Hampshire
we received significant funds when the
Act was created
and periodically we have received
additional funds related to the help of
America vote act those additional funds
usually require a state match of funds
currently the balance in the fund is
12.8 million dollars
um and there is another appropriation
that we have not received yet of roughly
another million dollars
you may have heard some issues related
to funds from Hava in the past one of
them comes up regularly when there's a
race for secretary of state that this
that the Secretary of State's office
inappropriately paid a million dollars
to fund construction up at the state
archives we have been through a couple
of audits on that uh you know on that
subject the most recent one was the
Federal audit
that specific to the Haba funds and they
concluded that those have a funds were
appropriately expended and in fact
spending the million dollars
as prepaid rent for the facility at the
help in the archives actually save the
taxpayers quite a bit of money by taking
that route and like I said there's no
question now that the way that money was
spent was appropriate and uh any subject
any suggestion to the contrary is simply
inaccurate
the the legislature when the help
America vote Act was passed uh
created the election Fund in the state
of New Hampshire where that money is
deposited and the legislature determined
uh that we would only spend a portion of
those funds in every any given year to
meet the requirements actually the
mandates of the help America vote Act
with the policy being that we would keep
as much of the principle as far into the
future as possible to fund those
programs so that we would not have to
fund the federal mandate by General
funds in the future so here we are 20
years later we still have a healthy
balance in that fund which allows us to
spend roughly a million dollars a year
uh that million dollars is spent on the
staff required to run the Java program
those are the individuals that that
maintain the Statewide voter database
that's a project it's staff that are
involved in the extensive local election
official training that we put on every
year the funds paid for the Statewide
voter registration database and we're
currently using funds to replace the
Legacy system that was built in 2006 of
the new system the new voter database
will be completed in 2024 I'm sorry 2023
sometime this summer we will have the
new the new database in place that
project was put out to bid and I believe
the price tag on is
some are close to four million dollars
so it's not a you know it's not an
inexpensive project
the money also pays for the accessible
voting equipment that you see in your
polling place when you go and vote
uh it that there's actually a white tent
that is set up and then when a voter
just a voter with disabilities goes in
to vote on the equipment they're able to
use a touch screen pad to make their
choices on their ballot and when they
are completed they they push a button
and an actual ballot goes through the
printer printing device and the printer
will make marks in the oval on the
ballot and then the disabled voter is
able to take that ballot and run it
through an optical scan voting machine
if that's what your polling place uses
or or directly in a Ballot Box if it's a
hand count town so uh the idea is that
the you know we want the voter with a
disability to be able to vote
independently and freely without
assistance if that is possible
I think we're on our second or third
generation of accessible voting device
in the polling place and again that
equipment is paid forth with ahava funds
for the 2022 election it
we had an online system which was
available to voters with site
disabilities where the voter similar to
a uocaba vote or a military who oversees
voter who are authorized to receive
their ballot by email
uh can then print it off vote on it and
then return it through a regular mail
the
voters besite disabilities were able to
vote in a similar manner so they could
receive their ballot at home by email
have a program on their computer that
would allow them to make the choices of
their candidates on the ballot they
could then print a ballot off and then
mail it back to the town clerks that it
um
and then I met as I mentioned uh you
know our
poll worker training is quite extensive
and those uh those training sessions are
um
so the the elections division which is
where we interact a great deal with this
uh committee
um you know the activities in general
that we conduct related to elections are
uh receiving campaign Finance filings
and we have an online
filing system
which has been problematic and the
reason for that is that we inherited
through the sale of a company a vendor
who has not been maintaining the system
properly for us I believe that they're
incompetent the contract with them
expires this spring and we already have
plans to replace the campaign Finance
system and that will be completed well
before the 20
2024 election cycle so that we have a
system that is running properly and
hopefully glitch free but I know it has
been embarrassing the way that uh that
system has worked in fact that same
vendor was uh was responsible for our
elections database and our corporations
database and we had significant issues
with them uh in both respects uh we were
able to get out from the corporations
contract with them last
uh last year we have a new vendor that
has completely upgraded that system and
it is working fantastic right now so
your constituents that will be doing
business filings should have a really
good experience now uh interacting with
Secretary of State's office in that
regard and then the elections database
of course is our users are local
election officials primarily Town clerks
and supervisors of the checklist and the
new system that we're building for them
is going to make their life a lot easier
too so we're really excited about that
um we received candidate filings in the
office
we issue notices to voters and all the
instructional Publications uh to the
local election officials that are
required by Statute
we prepare all of the ballots for the
elections and that involves receiving
the candidate filings uh
preparing the ballot with the candidates
names
we
incorporate the appropriate rotations
both for candidate name order and party
columns that appear on the ballot and we
do all of the proofing that is necessary
to make sure that the ballots are
accurate
and to the extent that um
that that's completed we deliver
the that information to the printer we
oversee the printing process which is
done by a local printer
we ship the ballots to the local
election officials when they're ready
make sure that they get there on time so
that especially the absentee ballots can
get out in a timely manner
we undertake again significant election
official training we conduct recounts
and then in the end we certify the
results
the
you know a number of the the initiatives
that are currently ongoing and have been
uh since uh last year uh we talked about
replacing the voter registration
database
um and that will have additional uh uh
ability and capability one thing that we
are looking at because I know it's a
topic of of this legislature and it was
uh during the last session but the
ability to have some kind of a voter
access portal where voters can interact
with local election officials on things
like filing voter registration
applications uh maybe being able to
request absentee ballots and things like
that and as that is created we'll
certainly seek the input of the you know
of the legislators
and voters and election officials on
what that might look like
we're currently looking at the next
excuse me
because we all know the devices that are
being used right now are decades old
they are reaching the end of their
useful life although I think we could
squeeze a couple more elections out of
them you know we are testing other
devices in the last
uh general election we tested an open
source voting device which is brand new
it's not I don't know that's being used
anywhere else in the country uh we had a
positive experience with that by the way
open source for those of you that don't
know is uh is software that is not
proprietary so that anybody that is
interested in looking at the code and
how the code programs the machined
account ballots can actually do that
there have been concerns about the
proprietary code which the major
companies that
provide ball accounting devices used
because you can't see how the software
is interacting with the counting of the
ballot
um
the software the open source software
that we used I think worked really
really well but the hardware design of
the actual equipment that was used to
you know run the ballots through did
have issues and those will have to be
addressed before that device could be
used
in in New Hampshire elections on a
regular basis
uh we will be testing additional devices
in the in the
Municipal elections this spring and fall
the ballot commission is meeting
tomorrow the battle law commission is
the agency that is approved that will
approve ballot counting devices uh they
are going to they've approved the device
manufactured by Dominion uh in the towns
of Milford and Londonderry
in March and uh and they're going to be
looking at a couple of other devices
manufactured by a company called es and
S and and another company clear ballot
uh tomorrow and so we'll see if they
give those approvals or not and if they
do I expect we'll be testing those this
March as well
uh e-poll books are have been approved
by the legislature for use we are seeing
growing use by municipalities uh we're
up to 15 polling places now that are
actually using uh e-poll books in the
poll books representing about 126 000
voters
um
the um
for the new members and E public an
electronic poll book is a an alarm an
electronic check-in device that is used
uh by a voter that can actually present
their driver's license and have the
device you know record that information
uh so that it doesn't have to be typed
in by the polar by the by the ballot
Clerk
and then the voter can proceed to vote
the benefit to the towns is that it
eliminates the need for lines set up by
alphabet a voter can go to the shortest
line and check in and then at the end of
the night when the polls close the
a Pogba can be closed out and then very
quickly a printout of the number of
Voters that checked in is available and
the supervisors of the checklist don't
have to go through and count the number
of Voters that checked in on each page
we're currently working on an interface
program so that the local election
officials at the municipal level will be
able to take the data from the
electronic poll book and actually
link it right to the voter database so
it will save you know it will save a
tremendous amount of time in entering
that data manually into the elections
database so you know we're pretty
excited about that
the use of the poll books is still done
in parallel with a paper checklist
we want to be absolutely sure before we
go to just the e-poll book uh
by itself that it's going to be
Fail-Safe and that there is that there
is a way to retrieve voters who have
checked in prior to an e-pol book
failure that's been an issue in some
other states that have used these and so
we're just being tremendously cautious
until we can
reach a certain confidence level that
um
we've expanded poll worker training and
we'll continue to do that we do
trainings in person in all regions of
the state we're using WebEx and actually
recording video training videos that
we've put up on uh
YouTube and other places our website
where the local election officials can
obtain them view them at their own uh
you know at their own pleasure uh and um
that's working well
uh we're we have growing efforts on
voter education last year we hired a
communications director Anna Faye she
did a tremendous amount of postings on
social media we had a bunch of election
fun facts hopefully you got to see those
on Twitter and YouTube
but those were really well received
we're doing a lot of work with the
traditional media we're engaging more
with speaking engagements to groups like
rotary clubs or you know anybody that
you know wants to learn about elections
and I would you know offer that to you
as well if you would like us to come to
your community to give a presentation
we're certainly more than happy to do
that
we have plans to engage in a poll worker
recruitment initiative this year uh you
know we're pretty excited about an
opportunity where we might be able to
focus on Veterans primarily you know
people that have helped defend our
country uh you know and serve to
promote democracy and involve them now
that they're retired from service to you
know help out you know continue their
civic duty in polling place and so we'll
be working with veterans groups on that
initiative
uh we continue to enhance enhance the
website we've done a tremendous amount
in that regard uh it's a lot more user
friendly uh more importantly it is
completely Ada accessible so that
individuals with disabilities can go on
and access all parts of the elections
website
it did require us to remove a lot of
content until we can make it Ada
accessible and as we complete that we're
putting that information back up we are
going to be working on a municipal
template that spends something that has
been suggested so that we can offer the
cities and towns in New Hampshire a
uniform website template related to
um we continue to work with
post-election audits that was a policy
decision of the legislature that
required Us in the last election to do
uh 10
state representative districts
it required us to take
state representative districts that had
to be recounted and from those ballots
count an office a higher office on the
ballot either
Governor U.S Senate Congress
uh maybe executive Council
so we completed that for 10 Towns which
were selected
in addition to that we had a high speed
scanner conduct an audit of four
polling places uh in the around the
state of New Hampshire of various sizes
those
audits were very positive I mean they
did they did validate the counts uh you
know on the ballots uh as being accurate
which was good the legislature also
required us to start keeping track of
undervotes and overvotes on the ballot
which had to be reported by the
municipalities and then as we did
recounts we also kept track of that
information during the recount
and it gave us quite a bit more
confidence
in the count and it also uh you know we
had the issue in Manchester Ward 6 where
with between the Audits and the and the
information uh that was collected
related to undervotes and over votes
made it very clear that there was an
undercount of ballots in that Ward six
uh
uh race
it put me in a very difficult position
because you know we're only allowed one
recount
um but we knew that there was a very
obvious error that all of the ballots
were not counted uh in that particular
race to me it didn't matter which party
was involved you know in the outcome
um but I had to struggle whether you
know
you know we were just going to go with a
status quo or whether because we knew
there was an error that we would force
the issue allow allow it to be taken to
court where a judge did decide that the
right thing to do was to count all of
the ballots in that race which is what
happened
um
the last thing that that I'll mention is
that related to our elections
initiatives is that we did have a a
special committee on voter confidence
which was a sounding board they you know
they went out around the state listened
from all
political parties and ideologies and you
know they heard a lot of issues related
to the elections that uh you know in
some some situations they were venting
sessions and I think that was a healthy
thing to go through they collected a lot
of information a lot of data a lot of
emails a lot of testimony uh the very
diverse committee got together
and over several meeting sessions did
come up with a report that was signed by
all but one of the members of the
committee
uh uh the the member that did not sign
also issued a report uh which was not
too much different from the report that
was issued by the committee itself but I
I there were no surprises in what they
recommended uh to me and I don't think
that there will be surprises to you but
I think it'll be really useful
information for the committee when
you're you know looking at the issues
that are going to be before you to see
what this bipartisan Group found uh uh
you know when they went around and
conducted that exercise so I think there
will be some positive things that come
out of that and I look forward to that
with policy decisions is that I want to
focus on the local election officials
because the legislature has been
throwing a lot at them over the last few
bienniums they are required to do a lot
more work there is a lot more scrutiny
on what they do I think we have to
remember that for the most part these
individuals are volunteers they do the
job because they want to participate in
Civic activity
um they do it be like because they like
it it's a social event for them
but to the extent that we continue to
burden them and make the job more
difficult and and place a lot more uh
you know challenging scrutiny and
observation on what they do I think
we're going to have a harder job finding
people to do that job and so you know
that's a challenge that I think we have
to be cognizant of as we move forward
and and just make sure that you know
that the people that really make the
elections in New Hampshire work are
treated properly and that we you know
that we make their job easier if we can
not harder and and just recognize the
important role that they play in this
process
so with that Mr chairman I think that
was a mouthful
we were all here to answer questions if
you have any
Aaron has been working a lot on uh the
fiscal notes that will be appearing on
the backs of the bills that you receive
and Patty has been doing a tremendous
amount with the reporting that's being
required at the federal level for the
election assistance commission and that
information includes uh you know the the
you know the number of absentee voters
we had the number of uh
verification letters that we had to mail
out for voters that you know registered
or obtained ballots using affidavits and
things like that
um
but we're all here as a resource you
know you you search any one of us out uh
Aaron and Patty will probably be the
ones showing up to testify on
legislation uh I'll be here this
afternoon just to uh you know kind of
continue with the orientation on how
that process will work from our end and
your end so we're happy to answer any
questions
thank you Mr secretary are there
yes representative Potomac Brown thank
you Mr chairman
welcome welcome back uh here we go again
I I want to ask about the
the
um Dominion
um
ballot Counting
equipment that will be used in
Londonderry and in Milton uh if you know
the model number offhand if you don't
that's that's okay too we can find that
it's the Dominion image cast
um it is the device that has been
criticized in the past by by certain
groups
um
but it's a it's it's a device that we're
going to test ultimately the ballot
commission makes the final call on which
devices are going to be approved in New
Hampshire the Dominion device is one of
four
um the ballot commission has set
criteria that they are looking at
and I think their plan is
probably to decide on one maybe two
devices uh
ideally we want to be able to just print
one style ballot for the State of New
Hampshire that can be read by any
devices that are used as opposed to
having different machines that require
different ballot Styles because that
will make our job a lot more complicated
if we have to do that
a follow-up Mr chairman follow up and
how will they be evaluated during and or
after the elections in Londonderry and
Milton the
the the tests that we're doing is just a
proof of comp concept we want to make
sure that the devices are going to work
well in a New Hampshire election number
one
excuse me number two the
the ballot commission has set criteria
that for the devices that will be unique
to New Hampshire some of the criteria
some examples are that the devices
cannot have
any modem capability
no ability to connect to the interfa
Internet or Wi-Fi so that's a
requirement
they have to be Standalone units
so that
the results from a machine will be
printed from that machine they won't get
sent to another location where the
results will be aggregated
by a central device
if multiple devices are used in a
polling place
the the tapes or the results that are
printed off the machine will have to be
added together at the polling place and
not uh you know not interconnected those
are examples
once that's done
the
the machines will have to meet
the new requirements technical
requirements that are established by the
election assistance Commission
the latest requirements have not been
completely approved yet but we expect
that that approval is going to be
forthcoming
and then once the election assistance
commission
establishes those
the manufacturer of the device is going
to have to take it before a certified
technical Laboratory
so that
the inner workings and the software of
the devices are tested and validated and
certified
further questions
representative boom
thank you Mr chair the law that was
passed last year which was my bill on
letting the town Clerks
notify the Secretary of State on on
State Rep filings daily how did that
work out
I think that worked out overall it
worked out pretty well we were receiving
the uh the filings by email uh pretty
much every day and then we received the
hard copy days later so
um
I think I I think I'll have to look but
we were publishing putting that
information up on the website as we were
receiving it so hopefully you know the
candidates knew who their competition
was earlier in the process
thank you
yeah I just want to say so this is my
seventh term and I typically help other
people running so I look at those
results they've never been up faster
really well done
thank you
representative Muirhead
thank you Mr chair
um look uh looking to the situation
Manchester Ward 6
and to the general problem that might
arise when there's a obvious error in a
recount
um but we're only permitted of course
one recount do you think we have the
right process for dealing with that
situation
um or do we need to stipulate what the
process should be when there's an
obvious error in a recount more
precisely than is now stipulated
I think that the process we have uh in
place works and and we may have to tweak
it just a little bit
excuse me to accommodate
you know the situation happened in
Manchester Ward 6.
what just being a little more specific
on what happened there was when the
return of votes came in from that
particular Ward it did not have the
undervotes listed on the page we did not
get that until sometime later the other
the other uh return of votes forms from
the awards in Manchester had that
information on it
and so
when we collected uh the information
during the recount
um you know we had those numbers
uh we had the numbers from the recount
itself but then when we did the the
audit you know where you know we had the
number of uh ballots that were cast and
uh and the number of undervotes and
everything for the the higher office
that we had counted when we when we
looked at the different
numbers that we had for ballots cast it
was clear that
in the recount we were we were well
under
the other numbers that we had
if we had not done those other exercises
we would have never known uh and that
election would have you know would have
been results would have been certified
and we wouldn't have known any better
but if the Dilemma was in this case we
knew that that there was an error based
on this extra information so you know
knowing that I think that there are
things that we can do uh
in running the elections using that
extra information
to to validate the results of the
recount before we actually announce the
numbers
um and I think you know that's where we
need to be
um
yeah
and I'll just leave it at that for now
may I have a follow-up please follow up
thank you
um to my understanding it correctly that
the um the new audit bill was the one
that gave us that extra information
yes that helps uh because Manchester
Ward 6 was one of the towns that was
audited
um and and that was by chance I mean it
wasn't because we thought there was an
issue there it's just that was that was
one of the awards that was selected
um
I I will say that too that we had a
record number of recounts uh in 2022
there were 31 recounts that were
requested and then on top of that uh we
had these audits that were going on at
the same time so uh I think we managed
the logistics of that really really well
um and uh you know Patty you know I
think did a tremendous job helping to
organize that entire effort and uh you
know we had a lot of new uh
recount workers helping the process so
they were on a learning curve themselves
um but I think we're really better
prepared for the future because of that
experience uh we have a much larger pool
of people that we can call on to help us
conduct recounts and uh I think we're
going to be better for the experience
that we had in this last election
thank you
thank you Mr chairman uh secretary with
the aging and uh retiring individuals
who are serving right now as election
officials in their towns uh is there any
effort to try and Recruit new uh poll
workers or uh if so what type of process
is going on to try and do that
that's going to be an effort that we're
going to organize this year so that
we're well prepared for 2024 and as I
mentioned earlier there is a program
that we're moving on working with
veterans groups to encourage veterans
you know who
it's a large part in helping us protect
our democracy actually participate in
the election process itself those
individuals that have been critical of
the election process or have concerns or
um you know we're encouraging them to
participate as well
um you know it's it's an important role
and if you actually participate in the
election and see uh how it works and and
see the checks and balances that are
really underway on Election Day in every
polling place
you have a better understanding of you
know how it works and how it really is
difficult to have a conspiratorial uh
manipulation of the election results and
you know you know we have to engage
the general population and help them
understand that process to help
build confidence
um so yeah we're going to be coming up
with initiatives doing a lot more
through the media encouraging people to
participate in the process and putting
out pieces that are educational so that
people don't want to participate at
least they can read about how the
process works
foreign
Mr chairman let me just add too that you
know there are materials that we place
on your desk you know there's an
election procedure manual there's a law
book with an addendum that provides the
changes that were made during the last
legislative session uh you have a state
constitution and a political calendar
which has all the important dates
related to elections in New Hampshire
representative Lynn
thank you Mr chair
um the machines that you're testing for
the the Dominion and all the other ones
that you're testing will they have the
ability to do ranked Choice voting in in
the event that is passed in in New
Hampshire
I believe that the the newer devices
which are digital scan as opposed to
Optical scan
uh have the ability to uh
to count ranked choice
voting towns but again it depends on
you know how that's going to look so you
know if New Hampshire were
that the problem with New Hampshire and
ranked Choice voting is that we have
some offices where there are many
candidates uh
you know primarily state representative
and so the question is how how is that
going to look you know how many you know
how many how many
choices as a person going to be able to
make is it the first five and then you
cut it off but there may be limitations
to to those machines the the new the
digital scan models are have the ability
to record images of every ballot
that goes through it has the the ability
to isolate a particular race and and the
marks that are made for that particular
race uh has the ability to
pull up
marks on the ballot that are
questionable so you know it starts off
with a completely filled in oval and
then it moves down the line until you
know you reach a point where it's just a
you know just a dot in the oval so
um there is a there is a a lot more that
those devices can do
whether we use that opportunity or not
is is a policy decision
um but you know if we do go that route
uh you know there are
uh
you know the the committee has a lot of
options on how we decide what the policy
is going to be and how we count ballots
follow-up this isn't actually a question
but I do commend the recounts uh system
that you add I participated in it and it
was very well done and
Patty did a great job everybody else on
the team so I would urge all the people
on this committee to do that because it
was very educational yeah thank you
thank you and thank Patty and Aaron
because they were a really big part of
representative work
thank you Mr chair
um secretary Mr secretary um
you mentioned involving the veterans and
doing that has there been any
consideration with the requirements for
civics education in the high school
level and and of involving high school
students in the voting process and and
that's a great question and there has
been discussion but there has been no
movement on that yet but but I think
that's a logical next place to go and uh
you know we will make ourselves
available to go to any high school or
college
you know that wants to have a
conversation about elections
um you know any time that we have an
opportunity or an invitation to do that
we take advantage of it um but I think
that it would be a good idea to maybe
come up with a curriculum in a more
formal way you know related to Civics
all right thank you Mr secretary this is
perfect
just gonna hang out yeah why not
I got some things I need counseled can
you help me
all right nuts and bolts times I don't
have to go through my first item because
everybody uses the mics correctly and I
am so happy
um done speaking
that doesn't happen a lot and if you get
enough of them lit up then nobody can
hear anything on the feed
decorum
these are instruments of the devil
so silence or dead or off or whatever
you want to do when they're in here but
we should never ever hear one it's
incredibly embarrassing especially if
you have a funny ringtone
a good friend of mine
who may or may not be another committee
chair has one ringtone set for I don't
know some radio personality and it goes
oh my God who the hell cares
in the middle of a hearing that thing
went off I could have strangled them
he had a reporter over his shoulder not
good so just yeah kill him
Bones on silent food drinks
we don't do it
um if you've got to bring water you can
put them underneath
it'd be nothing worse than having to
stop a public hearing so we could mop up
a mess so we don't do it if you need to
get a drink have a water bottle
underneath or just step out for a few
minutes
Electronics during public hearings
were not on our laptops or looking
things up on our phone we are
respectfully and politely receiving
testimony can have them up when we're
actually debating each other during
executive session but never during a
drawers the committee rooms right on the
other side of that wall and in there you
will find a drawer with your name on it
if you don't let me know open the drawer
there should be a key and you may find
other treasure as representative bum
discovered this morning there were some
leftovers in there
fortunately they were not perishable as
far as we know it but yeah you might
want to take a look at that and uh clean
it out
when people are testifying that there
are times you're not going to be here
you've gone to another committee to
testify on their own bill or you had to
come in late or you double booked it
happens so when you come into the room
if somebody's there testifying just wait
until they're done and then come up to
take your seat to do otherwise is
distracting
when you are interested in a bill before
this committee or are a sponsor or
co-sponsor that wasn't all you dude but
you did demonstrate
so when um you need to introduce your
bill to this committee you got a choice
to make you can go down there and
testify
or stay up here so that you can ask
questions afterwards but you cannot do
both so never go down there to testify
and then go back to your seat we don't
do it
okay the part you really want to know
about how's the schedule going to work
what is our workload I wish I could tell
you
um officer legislative Services has some
challenges they got a stack of new
attorneys who necessarily are not as
quick as the older attorneys who are
used to the process and a lot of them
also got sick right when the um the lsrs
were hit in the office there is still a
few hundred bills not assigned to
committees by the speaker because we
don't have them
so we will do that as quickly as we
receive them like when they hit the
office
they're done immediately but so I can't
tell you how heavy our workload is going
to be because I don't have the bills
So the plan is we're going to meet
Tuesdays if we have bills we're going to
meet Tuesdays if we have bills to exec
we're going to meet Tuesdays if I've got
a bunch of bills we'll do a full day
um because we don't know what comes
afterwards and what we don't want to do
is be in panic mode as deadlines
approach
so I like to front load it heavy and
then relax later on and maybe get a week
or so off as we get near the crossover
deadline
the executive sessions
here's how those are going to work now
this language in the calendar every time
we meet that says something like
executive session may occur throughout
the day
that is to facilitate if we get a super
easy bill
and representative Lynn and I agree on
what the outcome is going to be
we can together decide to exec it that
day we are unable to do that without
that language on the calendar that says
there may be an executive session so
that's why that's in there
in this community that's excuse me
probably going to be rare most of the
time they're going to be put up so
you'll get like you got a notice for
today you will get a separate notice
that says election law executive hearing
with a listing of the bills that we're
going to do
the I'd like to
do the two that we're going to hear this
afternoon next Tuesday and just
clear the work that's that's what I'm
I think I've covered everything about
how we're gonna operate do you have
that
[Laughter]
hey you know what I just finished my bit
so your timing is awesome
so let's hear from her and you guys can
ask me questions afterwards because I'm
no no no maybe they'll forget them
good morning everyone I'm Ann Edwards
from the Attorney General's office and
we have the election law unit at our
office our election law unit is uh
staffed by two full-time attorneys of
which I am not one of them
I am one of the supervisors who works
with them and also a full-time criminal
investigator and a full-time
investigative paralegal I've worked in
New Hampshire elections for the Attorney
General's office for more than 25 years
so I'm the institutional knowledge or
perhaps just to institutionalized
attorney over there who works closely
with them
our two attorneys are currently in a
criminal case mediation today that
involves an election matter
and I just want to give you some quick
statistics so you can understand what we
do as Secretary of State Scanlon said
we're the election law enforcement so we
work very very closely with the election
with the Secretary of State's office on
interpretation of Elections law because
we're also their attorney we provide
advice to the Secretary of State in all
of those areas that he described
including Securities and corporations we
are his general attorney but the
election law unit Works closely with him
on the interpretation of election law
and the enforcement of it
one of the areas that we have seen a lot
of action in the last year and many of
you have may have heard about this and
if not you will hear more about it is as
the Secretary of State said the campaign
filing system has been challenged shall
we say and so it's been challenging in
our office to try to deal with the
violations of the filings that different
candidates and campaigns and political
committees have had and so we have right
now 1600 violations for 2020. that's not
1600 people or campaigns it's 1600
violations so one campaign might have a
couple of violations the bulk of those
violations is that the reports are late
that's not necessarily uncommon and so
what we are in the process of doing is
we are not going to flood the market
with sixteen hundred letters all at once
but over the next two months we will be
issuing the letters to the different
entities
informing them of what the violations
are and requesting that they correct
those violations
if you perhaps see one of these letters
at some point you're going to see a
paragraph in it that notes that we might
be wrong and the reason we might be
wrong is because the campaign filing
system has challenges so we believe that
we are correct it has taken an
incredibly long time for us to go
through all of these documents to try to
make sure we're correct but don't be
surprised if we are not correct and you
hear complaints about that
we're trying to head those off of the
past but you are the most likely place
to hear about them
if we're incorrect we also are working
on the 2022 filings
those seem to not have quite as many
challenges on in the campaign filing
system so we're hopeful about that
every six months we issue a biennial
report on the election matters that we
have closed out during that time period
and the statistical information on the
number that we've taken in we have been
behind in those reports in the last few
years we have now caught up and we have
to the two reports on their way out for
um and that's a very helpful area for
all of you it specifically comes to the
House and Senate election committees and
the purpose of those reports is to
provide you with information and those
closeout letters and you can see a lot
of what we do on a day-to-day basis in
our office
we have an election line hotline that
hotline runs
every day all year long and then we have
an election hotline that goes on place
just for specific elections so for the
general election unit hotline I'll call
it in 2021 we logged 453 hotline calls
and we opened 60 of those as separate
matters that means that they needed to
be investigated or they needed to be
reviewed and letters needed to be issued
in order to deal with what
to to deal with what the issue was that
was complained about
in 2022 which was obviously and a a
general election year we logged 1085
hotline calls and 65 matters were open
so not necessarily many more matters but
many many more calls
in 2022 for the September primary the
election unit handled 158 different
inquiries and calls those are from
members of the public candidates
political parties local election
officials and sometimes different state
officials
the November for the general election we
handled 275 inquiries again from those
different types of groups
we do criminal prosecutions as I
mentioned the um our two other attorneys
are currently in court right now dealing
with one of those we brought four
criminal prosecutions during
2021-2022 and we had other ones that
were outstanding so we have resolved six
prosecutions in the last year and a half
we also have civil litigation matters
some of these are brought against us or
against the Secretary of State and some
of them are brought by us so in 2021 to
2022 we had six different litigation
matters those tend to be what we call
systems cases so their challenges to how
voter registration occurs their
challenges to as Secretary of State
state Scanlon mentioned voters who have
site impairment
and requested a different format to be
able to vote they we have been sued in
the past for the
signatures on absentee ballots and their
envelopes and whether or not we could do
signature checks to see whether people
had accurately signed their names so
those types of cases are the bigger
cases we also have a couple of
redistricting cases that were brought
some have been resolved there's a couple
that are still outstanding
we too sometimes are involved in
bringing cases so we brought cases
against the City of Laconia the town of
Bedford
and those two cases had to do with the
fact that we were trying to determine
um whether ballots that had been found
in one case in the City of Laconia there
were ballots that were found inside a
ballot counting device that had not been
counted from previous elections and in
the town of Bedford Bedford had found
he set a of ballots in 2020 that had not
been counted absentee ballots and so in
order for us to open the ballot boxes
other than for a recount we have to get
a court order so those two lawsuits
occurred in those matters we also sued
an individual who
um filed to become the county attorney
in Coos County and was not an attorney
so that was the first time we filed to
remove somebody from a ballot
and so those are the types of litigation
that we can be handling on a regular
basis
and finally we have uh with respect to
I guess I I won't call it litigation but
it's activity that ended up coming here
into the legislature and was ordered for
us to hold an audit which was different
than the audits that the secretary of
state was talking about in the case that
we handled it was the window audit where
there were questions about the
difference between the election night
count of ballots and the recount of
those same ballots and so the
legislature required a an independent
set of Auditors to run an audit and so
in May of 2021 we spent three weeks
recounting in just about any possible
way you could imagine the ballots for
the town of Windham
we work with the Secretary of State's
office in training all of the local
officials you'll see in the letters that
are attached to our by our biannual
reports that we will raise concerns with
election officials we have actually
asked some election officials to step
down from their positions including the
moderator of Laconia Ward 6 due to his
failure to make sure that ballots were
accurately counted thus disenfranchising
voters
and so in those cases we work very
closely to make sure the election
officials in those specific polling
places are trained but also the general
training for all election officials with
the Secretary of State's office
some of the major issues we saw around
the 2022 general election
and I'll just touch on these quickly our
public employees electioneering for the
matters that they're interested in we
have now issued a series of letters to
police departments and to mostly public
emergency response personnel as to who
is allowed to electioneer on a certain
issue that's involved in their community
and the fact that no matter who it is
who gets to a electioneer none of them
get to use public resources to do that
we also had some challenges in the 2022
general election with polling place
access some of those were seen on
television some of them were seen on
social media where we had polling place
access roads that became blocked because
of too much traffic and not enough
parking spaces generally that was the
combination that was very challenging
and we have some places where
the polling places just don't have
enough parking so we are working with
those communities to correct that prior
to the presidential
Primary in 2024.
we also have had many challenges to the
ballot counting devices those have been
ongoing and we continue to work on those
and we have had numerous domicile
complaints which some of those have been
raised with us
by private entities who have done their
own research and many of those we also
investigate on our own because they're
brought to our attention by local
election officials who may find that
someone is has filed for office or has
voted in their community and doesn't
appear to actually live in their
community
so those are the types of issues that we
handle we are available to come over and
answer any questions last year we worked
with this committee and with the senate
committee
on a piece of legislation that gave us
more authority to issue civil penalties
we have a lot of authority to charge
people with crimes including
misdemeanors we're not charging somebody
who has mistakes on their campaign
filing forms with misdemeanors it's just
not the right approach to take so we
have requested permission to find people
and even those fines can won't and can't
happen on the first violation but it's
more helpful to have finding Authority
particularly in the area of signs one
other area that we saw
rise during 2022 was the theft of signs
and we have at least one case in The
Lakes region where a candidate has
reported that more than a hundred of her
signs were stolen so we're working
through that that's part of a criminal
investigation at this point but we we
work very closely with all of those and
we do appreciate the finding and civil
penalty Authority so I'd be happy to
answer any questions thank you for
letting me speak
thank you very much and I'm glad you did
would you mind selling us who the
investigator is yes the investigator is
Dick Tracy
yes that's really Dick's name and
nicknamed his son that too one of his
sons so but dick is it dick is a former
captain from the Manchester police at
Manchester yes from Manchester police
department and he's been with our office
for I think at least 15 years dick is
excellent at what he does
and I am so sad that there are now
people young enough to not know how
representative O'Brien thank you Mr
chairman
thank you for coming uh you mentioned
something about a Laconia official uh
and you sent a letter asking them to
step down yeah so did I hear that
correctly okay did they and what is the
criteria that is used to send such a
letter that you make a determination
that you will send such a letter so the
official in Laconia was the moderator in
ward 6 and during the 2020 election
cycle more than 179 ballots were not
counted and so the criteria in that
position we didn't have the authority to
automatically remove that election
official but we believed that the loss
of voting for 179 individuals in ward 6
was a significant dereliction of the
responsibilities that the moderator had
sworn to undertake and so we requested
thank you Mr chair
um I'm at 1600 violations from the 2020
campaign
um
reports are still outstanding we're
expected like something having been due
September 30th 2020 and returned in
October 1st 2020. yes it's the it's the
latter so they have they were well
actually I say that I shouldn't say that
because for all 1600 I can't answer that
question but in in the case of some of
those individuals it may be that they
were supposed to have reported on
September 1st and they didn't report
until October 1st that while that might
not seem serious it is serious during an
election because it during that time
period if it was due on September 1st
the state primary occurred and so voters
do not have the information as to who
may have given contributions or what
expenditures may have been made by that
campaign during that time period so it
may be that it's corrected at this point
but we are going to note in those
letters that there is a violation that
occurred on the other hand there may
very well be circumstances where
individual individuals didn't ever file
and so they were late in that but they
then didn't file and perhaps they didn't
win their election and maybe never
became a candidate again so they've got
a late filing there and they don't have
try and try your microphone again
all right so for these violations uh for
individuals who may have lost their
campaigns or hypothetically uh served
for a number of years uh I I know that
there were uh rules on the books that
said that you could not that you didn't
need to file if you hadn't spent over a
thousand dollars
um are you are you looking at those uh
so we review all of the statutes in all
of the filing requirements so if there
are individuals who didn't
it
the only I guess I'm trying to think of
exactly how to answer this because it
all depends on WE somebody doesn't come
to our attention as having to file a
report and told they either file a
report because they've
collected or or expended 500
or because somebody usually an opponent
of theirs reaches out to us and says
they've collected five hundred dollars
they had a fundraiser and they haven't
reported to you so other than that we
don't go out and try to determine
individuals so with respect to whether
somebody had to file a report once
you're in the reporting system there are
certain reports that have to be filed
including the report that needs to be
filed six months after the election if
you have any more funds and so if
somebody hasn't filed that report then
and now we know what makes the mics
Crackle
representative Brennan
you mentioned that you'll be working
with communities to resolve challenges
at polling locations
um mostly traffic congestion or lack of
parking how do you identify those
communities is that a complaint or are
you saying that communities need to have
a certain number of parking spaces to be
a polling location is that something
that you're evaluating all communities
or
noise
so we it's usually as a result of a
complaint and it's usually a complaint
on Election Day and it's multiple
complaints so in the communities that
we're talking about these are
communities that absolutely struggled
for Access and during what so that you
all know what happens during election
day is one of the things that we do
there are a group of about five
attorneys in our office who have done
election work over the years who stay
and manage the hotline that comes into
our office so when problems like that
come up and I won't name any communities
because it's unfair to them
at this point but we spend a lot of time
on telephones the telephone with Chiefs
of police in particular so it's usually
the chief and the moderator who we have
on the phone trying to figure out what
it is that can be done to break the Log
Jam that's happening so that voters can
get in there and we come up with all
sorts of ideas and they come up with all
sorts of ideas and we work as well as we
can to solve the problem on Election Day
and I'll tell you that we have never in
all the years that I've done this and on
all the years we've had problems like
this never have we had a community that
just sort of sat back after the election
and waited for us to show up they're
already working on it they know they
have a problem and it's their voters and
their residents and they don't want to
have that problem either but sometimes
it just takes all of us to sort of push
foreign
thing but yes you're up thanks
thank you
um is it your office that does the voter
affidavit paperwork
say that somebody comes in without their
license we take their picture
and then they sign off on an affidavit
is that your office that does that
follow-ups
so first it's the Secretary of State's
office that does the follow-up on that
and the Secretary of State's office
using different resources it has
available we'll try to determine whether
the individual who is signed an
affidavit because they didn't have some
piece of information to be able to prove
they were qualified as a voter or to
prove who they were the Secretary of
State's office will do the first run at
those and see whether or not they can
identify all of those individuals when
they come to the end of their resources
then they come to us and at that point
we can use law enforcement information
to be able to do additional searches
though I'll tell you back to Dick Tracy
most of the time he finds people on
Facebook or social media of some type
that is the way that we can identify
pretty quickly somebody and where they
live or where they lived during that
anyone else
all right thank you very much that was
great
okay
so we've run through our program what's
going to happen this afternoon it's yes
um I'm Patty Lovejoy senior deputy
secretary of state
um one issue that is new this year that
it's going to be happening next month
for those of you who are new on the
committee is
um in the last election a provision for
provisional ballots
um was passed and this special election
will be the first time that provisional
ballot is in place so it's it's an issue
you may want to
um follow over the next month to see how
that process worked in this special
election plus they will
um be in place for the March elections
so this is something that's completely
new for the State of New Hampshire and I
just wanted to put it on your radar that
it will be in place for this special
election
okay
as it was mentioned people in the past
have followed have filed an affidavit do
you show up at the polls without your ID
you fill out a challenge voter
um affidavit you attest that you are who
you are and they take a picture we later
then send something to make sure that
that you are what's happening now with
the provisional ballots and I said this
was passed in the last legislature
and it takes place starting in 2023
now you will be given a packet
that you have to return to the Secretary
of State's office within a given number
of days that provides the information
that you didn't have on Election Day if
you do not provide it
then
we will notify you know what your town
that so and so did not provide that
information then the moderator will go
and retrieve your ballot
and remove the whoever you voted for
from the final tallies
uh and you're saying well how do they
know my ballot versus somebody else's uh
you will have a numbered affidavit
ballot so
when you vote you don't have the
information the moderator is going to
record on your ballot this is affidavit
ballot number one and they're going to
keep track of that so they will notify
they will send that list to the
Secretary of State's office
as we get all of that information in and
we have to provide these envelopes with
which the post office no longer
guarantees overnight but that's another
issue
um but if we don't receive them
by a certain date
we will then notify the town
that affidavit ballot number three and
number eight did not Retreat did not
return
their information in time
and then the moderator will pull ballot
number I don't remember what numbers I
said if it was two and eight we'll we'll
pull ballots two and eight and whoever
they voted for or whatever worn article
Etc that they voted for their votes will
be removed before the final vote is so
this is the first time
in New Hampshire history that we are
going to have provisional ballots
um obviously this bill came through this
committee and it was worked quite a bit
between this committee and um
and senate elections so I just wanted to
I I'm sure that secretary
he just didn't think about bringing
bring it up but it is something that's
that's coming up and you may want to pay
attention to how easily or how difficult
sorry
there are absentee ballots as there are
in any election they are doing it during
the vacation week and they're
specifically doing it during the
vacation week so that they can use the
um the school
gymnasium as they have as they have done
they didn't want to have for this
special election a special place to to
vote they didn't want to confuse any of
the voters but as in any election there
are absentee ballots available the you
will cover ballots will be going out to
any um any voters who uh you know have
in
regards to the
um
They will receive a packet right when
they register so they come in to vote
they don't have their ID
they will normally you get you get your
your picture taken it's put onto the
challenge voter affidavit at that moment
the voter will receive this packet from
the Secretary of State's office that has
the overnight
um mailing envelope and specifically
what it is that they need to provide if
they go on vacation
and they don't take care of this
beforehand
their ballot is not going their their
ballot will um be pulled because they
won't have gotten the information to the
Secretary of State's office in time so
if you voted and you had a challenge uh
voter the the best
the best practice is to be go home
complete the information get it sent off
to the Secretary of State but if you
wait till you at the end of the vacation
your your affidav your ballot will have
been
for the provisional ballots will
the metrics or the metadata on the the
number of provisional ballots in a given
election be reported to you know in the
same way that undervotes and
over votes are now uh being reported is
there some provision for the reporting
of that statistic
the the bill did not have Provisions I
mean obviously it's any information
um to do with elections is public
information so if somebody requests and
I'm sure this committee will
somebody on this committee I'm sure will
um ask how many provisional ballots
there were and how many were satisfied
that information will be
so assume I mean this election obviously
was a tied election so the chances that
this one might be close are are probably
pretty good
um if you know if on Election night it's
off by you know somebody wins by two and
there are eight
um provisional ballots the we will not
certify
the winner until after the provisional
ballot time frame has gone by
yeah
um
right
so I swear
foreign
[Music]
welcome
get
the thing is it could be
the same
it's just uh oh it was the freezing on
all right I apologize to everyone for us
being late but we will open the public
hearing on House Bill 101 welcome
thank you Mr thank you Mr chair happy to
be here
so uh we'll get right to this uh I I'd
like everyone to cast their minds back
to 1996 to start and I and I have sent
electronic uh copies of this
correspondence to the committee
so any of any of you who weren't around
in 1996
um will will hopefully trust my history
here so uh GOP Governor Steve merrow uh
opted not to run for re-election as some
of you will call them so that opened up
a it created an opening for governor uh
state senator Gene Shaheen immediately
declared her candidacy and she ran on a
post and the Democrat Democratic primary
now on the Republican side uh
Congressman Bill zelloff the late Bill
zealth declared a gubernatorial
candidacy and he was the strong favorite
uh overwhelming favorite
uh now conservative activist Ovid
LaMontagne who who I like uh also ran a
very long shot campaign for the GOP
nomination if you gave him any any
chance but On That September 10th of
1996 uh LaMontagne stunned Zelf edging
him out with 47 556 votes two forty
three thousand three ninety three and
you can look it up
uh uh State Senator Shaheen received
only 52 328 votes and getting the
Democratic nomination but that November
Shaheen trounced uh LaMontagne to become
governor uh she'd go on to become the
first woman to serve as both governor
and senator uh very historic and very
consequential for our state and indeed
for our country what happened in 1996 so
what happened in 1996
the Republican primary gubernatorial
vote was almost double that of the
Democrat Democratic vote and yet Shaheen
trounce LaMontagne in the general
election now interestingly even though
she received only uh 52 000 votes in the
primary she received two 284
000 votes in the general election
so what happens seems to involve a
concerted effort on the part of some
folks from from one party to declare his
independence or unaffiliated and and
frankly to control the outcome of the
other party's primary uh the the popular
zealth
had experience and name recognition and
probably it was seen as near unbeatable
in a general election
and despite passionate conservative
conservative support LaMontagne had
limited experience and could be
portrayed by some as an idea ideologue
uh as I said in a let go of it
so so the other party seems to have gone
all in for LaMontagne over zealth in
that September 1996 GOP Primary and and
this is going to take on a partisan
flavor and and I I feel a little bad
about that uh I have a lot of great
friends in the other party family
members
co-sponsors but it is what it is and I
just feel I need to say these things
because they need to be said
so
um
there were folks as a as I've said
before who seem to clearly have uh
signed on to vote in the GOP Primary who
obviously were not Republicans and and
really did not want Zelf to be the the
nominee so how do we know this well Sun
admitted it one told me directly and the
numbers bear this out Shaheen's primary
vote total was only slightly ahead of
that of both zealots and lamontagues and
I read to the numbers uh zof LaMontagne
combined for almost a hundred thousand
votes
to Shaheen's 52 000 as erstwhile
Independence Undeclared or unaffiliated
voted for LaMontagne so why does this
matter today well fast forward to 2022.
just a few months ago
one party apparently again made a
concerted effort to intrude on the other
party's primary and pick their preferred
opponents in several Federal Federal
races in particular how do we know this
well because again some folks admitted
it and it's documented that one party
literally spent millions of dollars to
influence the other party's primary
outcome was this legal maybe maybe not
not technically was it unethical maybe
and actually some of the shenanigans
were illegal
according to published reports for
illegal political mailers were sent to
the second CD District
which were identified by state legis
State investigators but but both the
mailing company
that sent the mailers in this
politically connected Law Firm refused
to identify the customer according to
the New Hampshire Attorney General
so Reynolds DeWalt and this is a public
record a direct mail Printing Company
New Bedford Massachusetts admitted to
sending the mailers but initially
refused to say who paid for them
so here are some fresh numbers
from just last September in the second
CD primary GOP candidates received 63
868 votes
any Custer received only 48 630 votes
and yet like like Shaheen in 1996 Custer
rolled to an overwhelming general
election Victory it is what it is it was
what it was so it seems apparent that
many again non-republicans voting in
Republican primaries are selecting
candidates that most Republicans don't
want
it's uh some see it is unethical some
see it as scandalous now who says so
Democrats with Integrity who are
embarrassed in the policy so 34
prominent National Democrats of
Integrity signed an open letter
decrying the shenanigans the the
mischief
one of the signatories was New Hampshire
Democrat dick sweat of BOE a former
Congressman former Ambassador so to
close this out I'm going to read in part
what uh
Congressman sweat signed on to quote
as members of the democratic party we
are dismayed by the recent practices of
democratic organizations intervening in
Republican primaries to promote
candidates these destructive primary
tactics aim to elevate Republican
candidates who Democrats hope they can
more easily beat in November but it is
risky and unethical to promote such
candidates we must stop this practice
and stop today unquote that from
Congressman sweat thank you Ambassador
sweat so New Hampshire's primary
elections are are seen by many is to be
compromised many of us think it's wrong
many of us think it's unethical many
many of us think it's it's scandalous it
creates cynicism it's some of us think
it is a blight on our electoral
processes and an embarrassment to our
state
but many folks wink and Nod and Snicker
at the at the mischief
hbo1 excuse me HB 101 would fix this
Democratic primaries would be for
Democrats Republican primaries would be
for Republicans imagine that
and yes we know the arguments against
closed primaries and yes we know about
40 percent of our electorate our
independence erstwhile Independence
but but c'est la vie
uh so I know the spill as you have it
may need to fine-tuning with dates I
know you have other bills that you're
going to be taking up on moving the
primary dates uh that may or may not
happen that is really going to be
determined in this committee
so uh because the committee will own
these bills you obviously can amend this
one or other ones that will and finally
there is a wonderful 1939 movie I know
many of you have seen it 1939 called Mr
Smith Goes to Washington
Jimmy Stewart played a guy named
Jefferson Smith a man who was appointed
to uh to be a senator from
from a western state you know it's the
the movie's Loosely based on an actual
senator in the 1920s who was who went to
Washington from Montana and was
horrified by the shenanigans and the
Mischief going on and what some now call
the swamp but in the movie Jefferson
Smith took on the uh these Corrupt
Practices shined a light on them and
made a difference
this inspiring movie was nominated for
11 Academy Awards so I just hope that we
can find some New Hampshire versions of
Mr Smith to address the uh the
shenanigans that are happening in our
state so thank you Mr chair and I'd be
happy to take any questions
thank you other questions from the
committee
yes
thank you for taking my question hello
um so I just need a clarification in
paragraph three
it says no basically says no Undeclared
person
uh
shall affiliate with the party within
four months of the state primary
election so does that mean
you have to uh register if you want to
vote for a party in the primary you have
to register for that party before four
months sure yes thank you for the
question it's a good question and yes
there's a need obviously to if some
measure such as this is to move forward
there needs to be some timelines and
some deadlines and so those are the
deadlines that we that we put in as is
there necessary and as I said before if
this were to be and I know this will go
to exact session and I don't know what
will happen with it but you certainly
can uh look at the at these deadlines
and timelines
um
um and I think it would be healthy to
look at those as I said before if the
other measures that seek to change the
primary date if this committee uh
recommends any of those then then these
deadlines and timelines certainly could
be uh you know we thought or adjusted
okay and follow-up question follow up
um so so then the next sentence means
that if a person is is registered with
the party they can't change their party
um
until before the first Wednesday in June
yes thank you and that's correct again
there needs to be some
um definition and timelines again
deadline so uh that is the the intent of
the first Wednesday in June and the day
before the state primary election is to
provide that definition in those those
deadlines or timelines but certainly uh
you all could
could could change if if you if you
wanted to okay okay thank you very much
representative thank you Mr chair
thank you representative taking my
question
um you've uh compared in in the gubernet
trial race in 1996 and I think the
second congressional district race 2022
the primary vote with the general
election vote for governor former
Governor Shaheen and congresswoman
Custer
um
what fraction let's just look at the
Custer race from 2022 what fraction of
Representative Custer's general election
vote do you would you expect to see
um show up and vote for her in the
uncontested primary
that that's a great question
um and I've thought about that is as I
looked at these numbers uh
given the relatively small numbers of
votes that that both Custer or Shaheen
got in the in the primaries that I
mentioned and then the huge votes that
they get in the general election so some
of that's to be expected and thank you
for the question excellent question what
I've already thought about
uh there is obviously more
participation in a general election uh I
know Secretary of State's here he can
speak to this much better than me but in
terms of anticipated percentages that's
that goes to the to the nub of the
concern here is that many of us given
the huge numbers that the two candidates
they mentioned received in the general
why were there
um their primary Turtles comparatively
so small uh
and that is what led some of us to think
that many people who uh supported either
Senator state Senator Shaheen or uh
congresswoman Custer
um just didn't vote for her in the
primaries they chose to vote and the
other primary to influence that outcome
so what percentage would I expect I
would have expected frankly to answer
the question that the percentage of
voters for both those candidates would
have been much higher in the primary and
why wasn't it that way that's the point
of uh my earlier testimony does that
answer your question at all or thank you
representative
thank you representative
the way I understand this then if you
moved into New Hampshire
within the four months or whatever the
whatever the period is you would not
then be able to select
either party Democrats or Republicans
if you move into the state New within
that time period
yes thank you that's another great
question and I'm so happy to see the
Secretary of State here because it's
something uh he may be able to speak to
better than me because the again is to
the earlier question the necessary
timelines and deadlines
could conceivably preclude some folks
from participating in the primary the
same way that they do now
so I think the timelines and deadlines
are essential and necessary great
question because if somebody does move
in
um would they be precluded by this
language from from registering to vote
in a primary and uh that's something
that I uh and those of us who care about
this you know talked about
um but the purpose of a closed primary
is to ensure the Integrity of the
primary and that the people who vote in
the primary are truly members of the
party now going way back
um and I've been around for a while in
New Hampshire there used to be deadlines
so you had to uh you know register to
vote like 30 days or whatever different
times in our history and now we've come
to this model where we have same-day
registration that is another issue but
uh again thank you for the excellent
question and um a
look forward to the Secretary of State
if he gets a chance to say anything to
maybe touching on that does that help
you at all
follow up uh well it's technically not a
follow-up so if there's anybody else you
can come back to me
um then I have a it's not a follow-up
it's a new question the existing statute
allows a party to only allow party
members to vote in their primary
so my question is if this is something
that the Republicans or the Democrats
wanted to do don't they now have the
mechanism to do that
okay thank you for the question so you
just stated that the existing statute
allow only allows
party members to vote in primaries today
I'm going to have to look at that again
I don't want to give you an answer
unless I'm exactly sure how I'm I'm
praising it so
um that's a piece of this I want to look
at again in terms of party control over
uh
uh you know registering or participating
in a primary and for the third or fourth
time I uh I'm so pleased that the
secretary of state is here because I he
uh
I'm sure could could explain some of the
history or how that works better better
all right thank you representative
and now we begin the part where I mangle
names I will do my best
all right you gotta hit the button on
the right it'll light up red
there you go
all right my name is Charlotte Pogue I'm
registered in I'm and as Undeclared in
the town of Brookline
and as was mentioned there are more
registered undeclareds than there are
Republicans and more than there are
Democrats
if this bill passes my understanding is
that undeclares will be disenfranchised
for primaries at least unless they
re-register as Republican or Democrat
four months before the election
before many people have even made up
their minds
and that's an imposition
I'd like to see government of the People
by the people and for the people instead
of what we have now which is government
of the parties by the lobbyists and for
the money
um my ideas for better elections how
about open ballots even in the primaries
put everybody on the ballot
uh I can vote for a republican for
governor and a Democrat for
I don't know
um dog catcher and uh
another idea which I really favor is
um
and if we really want to get somewhere
we could eliminate the parties because
to me party Warfare is why government
very often fails to govern for the
people
um
let's say just as an aside I volunteered
to work for the election this year
because they needed people to check in
and I was told that I couldn't do that
because I was Undeclared the rules are
there must be an even number of people
checking in voters and half of them must
be Republicans and half of them must be
Democrats no one declared so I needed to
re-register just to volunteer to help
with the with the recent election and
then get myself back to Undeclared
afterwards I don't know I just feel
Undeclared are not getting the proper
respect
so I'd like to see this particular law
not pass thank you very much
Stephen Bourne
good afternoon
um I'm obviously Stephen Bourne for
those of you who don't know me you'll be
seeing quite a bit of me this year
throughout these hearings as I was at
quite a few last year
um I'll be speaking
um against measures that are not in the
best interest of the state and I'll be
speaking four ones that do help us get
more engaged and choose to spend more of
our time to manage all the government we
buy every year whether that's you know
local state county or federal
um why well my hobby is to get our
client to get all of our citizens to
choose to spend a small fraction another
time
helping to better manage all the
government services we buy every year
so for the past Dozen Years if you don't
know I've been running our local Civic
group where we put out a monthly email
that says what went out of town what are
the key things from select board
planning Etc the goal is to help people
before more educated and more informed
and hence participate more in in our
government
so and also the national civic league
has got back to us and told us they
haven't found anyone across the country
that does quite what we do as far as our
newsletter the citizens handbook guide
the analysis of budgets Etc I also
published the New Hampshire common
denominator newsletter so if you want to
get involved in one of these
non-partisan groups across the state how
do you do it who do you get involved
with and so that's what the New
Hampshire common denominator newsletter
does today is an against day
okay you were elected to represent the
people not a political party
um it was in sort of embarrassing this
measures even being discussed because it
doesn't pass the first litmus test that
I have is how does it help all the
people it's focused on helping just the
parties all right
um
all right it actually does the worst of
the ox is the opposite it's creating
more barriers and obstacles to get
people to get involved one of the things
that the representative didn't mention
when he talks about how many people
participated in the primary it's an
incredibly small number
all right we should be focused on what
do we need to get to do to get more
people across the board involved in
voting in the primaries this is a Jim
Crow type of of law that we're putting
and we're having to spend our time to to
work on this all right I'm not going to
go line item by lie item on this measure
you know cutting it to shreds because I
assume no one's really going to be
supporting this moving forward
um because it as it was mentioned
earlier things like this if it does pass
we'll drive even more polarization and
that's not what we need
um and I think one of the questions you
know pointed out one of the absurdities
of the way it's written today the dates
may change but as an Undeclared voter
you want me to pick my party before I
even know who's running the filing
period doesn't even start before this
the clock starts how am I going to know
which side I want to vote for when I
don't even know who's put their name in
the Hat all right it's impossible to
make that decision as an Undeclared
voter all right
um you know you also have to remember
that our constitution does not say we
must have political parties our state
laws are set up so that they can't exist
all right do the political parties pay
for these primaries no they do not all
right they're a gift from all of us that
we contribute to make them happen all
right this committee may be secretary
Scanlon could help I have no idea what
the Secretary of State's office has to
spend to produce all those ballots
manage it control all that Etc you got
the supervisor of the checklist I mean
the primary jobs to make sure who can
vote in the general elections in the
local elections you know keeping track
of the R's and D's and everything else
is an additional task that also we have
to pay for just some back of the
envelope math My Town 2022 budget had a
thirty thousand dollar line item uh that
was for three elections so if we take a
third of that all right that's ten
thousand dollars there's 326 polling
stations across Hampshire all right
let's round down call that three million
dollars all right that is spent on those
primaries don't even talk in the
presidential primary just the president
that we're spending
um we heard that you know the numbers
the last posted from the Secretary of
State 36 percent the representative said
it's around 40 they're Undeclared voters
but if we just call that a third us
Undeclared voters are paying a million
dollars
a year for primaries that it's going to
be very difficult to participate and
that you're raising the bar for us to
get involved with
um the earlier speaker mentioned and I
assume that uh representative Moffett is
going to start working with the
representative Reed behind me who is
putting forth on legislation to rank
Choice voting I think if he you know put
his efforts and others behind ranked
Choice voting this bill would have never
ever come because we won't need it when
there's things like right choice voting
any questions for me
I'll answer them
there do not appear to be any thank you
all right you and you came late last
year I gave um the last chairman a copy
of my book but I didn't bring any with
thank you
um
I have a copy of my statement and I'm
probably just going to read it but
before I do that
I just wanted to comment on a couple
things that are not in my statement
um I would I would like to draw your
attention to a group called open
primaries they may or may not have
submitted something online for this I
don't know there's also a group called
Center for a an independent and
sustainable democracy that just opened
up at Arizona State University
and both groups are doing a lot of
research on the impact of independent
voters in our country and on open versus
closed primaries
and I know that open primaries recently
sponsored a a research project that was
done out of Princeton University that
showed that in very very that there
really is very little Mischief that
takes place in open primaries I know it
was somewhat of an issue this last year
but overall when they do the research it
it gets more attention and more word
than the actual data shows that the
actual data shows that there's very
little Mischief that takes place in open
primaries by party rating that that
really does not happen it is talked
about and maybe a very few people do it
but it's not something that impacts the
outcome
so I of course am speaking today in
opposition of HB 101
I'm a resident of Amherst New Hampshire
my family and I have resided here for
nearly nine and a half years
I'm registered as an independent
Undeclared with a party
I'm also the president of New Hampshire
independent voters as well as president
of New Hampshire ranked Choice voting
but I speak today
in my hat as president of New Hampshire
independent voters and as as a resident
and Undeclared voter myself
um both of those groups are 100 percent
uh comprised of Citizen volunteers and
are nonpartisan and non-profit
I'm also a licensed attorney here in the
state of New Hampshire
I have spoken before on similar bills in
the past and some of you have already
heard what I have to say but I noticed
that this committee is comprised of many
new members that have never heard these
these things so
as you've already heard today in New
Hampshire there are more voters who are
registered as Independents or Undeclared
than registered as either Republicans Or
democrats then the numbers are always in
flux but we have almost 40 percent
registered Undeclared uh 31 registered
Democrats and 30 percent registered
Republicans in the state of New
Hampshire with the last data that I
checked
New Hampshire has a long tradition
of allowing this large independent
Undeclared voting Bloc to participate in
its state-funded primary elections
uncleared voters are currently allowed
to show up at the primary election on
primary election day choose a party's
ballot cast their vote and then they can
reassert their desire to be Undeclared
on their way out the door
but by requiring voters to register with
the party at least four months before
the primary election in order to be
eligible to vote in the primary HB 101
would do away with this tradition and it
would disenfranchise independent
Undeclared voters who have purposely
chosen not to affiliate with the
political party
we New Hampshire independent voters
assert that no person no person should
be required to register with a political
party as a condition of voting in a
determinative public election
Although our current Party primary
system is for the selection of party
nominees
that selection will determine who will
appear on the general election ballot
and it has a huge ramifications as to
who are representatives in public office
will ultimately ultimately be
independent voters should not be shut
out from these consequential decisions
although I have not had the opportunity
this year to contact the leaders of the
Democratic and Republican parties about
their position on HB 101
I do believe that this committee should
do so
because if either party is opposed to
this bill
this bill would be unconstitutional
public records shows that the parties
were against a similar bill in the past
and I have a source here
um
this is a quote from the source that
came from the Republican bylaws
committee I think it was of 2021
if we were to adopt a close primary it
would be very likely result in a drop in
participation in Republican primaries
and or a boost in registered Democrats
it may also put our first in the nation
presidential primary in Jeopardy by
reducing the number of Voters who would
participate
I believe that the New Hampshire
Democratic party would also feel similar
similarly about closing their primaries
if the parties themselves are opposed to
closing their primaries the state should
not close them by Fiat not only do
independent voters believe independent
voters are group we believe that it's a
violation of the equal protection clause
for parties to close state funded
primaries although the uh are for
parties to use the state to close
state-funded primaries
although that has not been determined
that's just what we believe should be
the determination
but what the Supreme Court has
determined
and they have opined that it's
unconstitutional a violation of the
right of Association
for the state to close primaries when
the parties desire them to be open
and that comes from
the case tajahan versus Republican party
of Connecticut
1986 case
so as an Undeclared voter in New
Hampshire and as president of New
Hampshire independent voters I
respectfully ask you to vote HB 101 to
be inexpedient to legislate as it will
just disenfranchise so many independent
Undeclared voters we independent voters
do not vote based on party we tend to
view issues in a more careful and
nuanced fashion than simply accepting
the party line or party talking point
and when it comes to candidates we
prefer to vote for the person over the
party
sometimes we may select a republican
ballot sometimes we may select a
democratic ballot and not for Mischief
but because that's based on our
conscience of who we want to vote for
the most we wish we could vote for
different parties and different races
but we have to vote all one party in One
race even as it stands now it'll be even
worse if we have to register four months
before we probably just won't vote in
the primary which is really sad
so for the um sometimes we vote for
third party or independent candidates it
always depends on the issues and
circumstances
so for this and other reasons we do not
want to be required to register with the
political party in order to have our
voice heard in determinative primary
elections in order to have a say as to
who will appear on the general election
ballot
thank you
representative Lynn thank you and it's a
simple question
um I'm taking I'm taking uh the clerk's
place and you mentioned a group in
Arizona and I just wanted to get the
name of it because I couldn't write best
enough
it's the center for an independent and
okay we're under we're in a lot of
pressure to be nice and not too partisan
so I'll I'll I will uh abide I will
abide by that as well well as I can um
well first of all some of the claims
representative Moffett to claim I find
uh implausible um being bipartisanship I
happen to be a friend of uh over at
LaMontagne who have a lot of respect for
even though I disagree with him on many
issues and I'm pretty sure uh
he won that primary back in 1996 because
more Republicans favored him over uh
whoever it was Bill zeliff and he came
uh he's come close in a couple other
primaries I think certainly his success
is not because of Democrats crossing
over to metal in the primary I'm a very
I'm a very partisan Democrat I'm also a
member of my town committee as well as a
rep and I can guarantee you that
we're not we're just not organizing to
get people to vote in the other party's
primary we have enough trouble getting
people to vote in our own primary for
candidates they like and
some some of the more independent uh
Democratic minors voters might
occasionally cross over to Republican
primary if they think ours is boring but
that would be more
to vote against someone they really
don't like rather than putting someone
who's a weak candidate uh and just to
increase the Democrats chance and um you
know both parties
both parties uh we I have to admit have
put up some pretty questionable uh
candidates
um
uh I think Bob Burns also probably beat
George Hansel fair and square that was
not because of anything Andy Custer
doing George hansel's problem was
probably that Andy Custer was much
better at being a Democrat than than he
was but you know I uh Bob Burns I don't
think was that terrible the candidate
and
um
and uh you know we've had we had like
we've had like three very weak uh
Governors candidates and we did a lot
better when we got uh Senator Sherman
and I
don't think Molly Kelly or Colin van
Oster or Dan feltis won because
Republicans were crossing over and
voting in our primary they won our
primaries on the road merits and they
did the best they could in both the
primary and the general election so
I think this bill is uh certainly
anti-small D Democratic it's also taking
away a long-established right that our
citizens most of whom are neither most
of whom are registered as Undeclared and
even most of the Republicans and
Democrats are not as partisan as those
of us who are
office or lead the party apparatus
so I think it's unfair it's unfair that
it takes away A Long established right
at a time when there's a perception that
voting rights are under attack and um
it's also it's also unnecessary I mean
if you uh
rather than mandating close primaries I
think there's already a provision that
they can have a convention if already
prefers not to have a primary and if you
want to allow foreign
area that uh
idea might have some bear in mind it
would be incredibly unpopular and
probably would not help that party at
all in the uh in the general election so
I
just speaking as a so just anyways just
begins to state representative and the
citizen of New Hampshire and also like
uh somebody who uh somebody who
has a certain affection for overall
maintained in particular who I think was
unfairly uh maligned here I would say uh
this bill is
a terrible idea and uh you should uh itl
it at your first opportunity thanks
thank you
questions
thank you Mr chair and honorable members
of the committee for the record my name
is Ellen Reed and I represent Newmarket
and new fields and I have to admit I
feel kind of bad because I feel like
we've been beating up on the prime
sponsor so far non-stop uh string of
opposed but um I I am also opposed to
this bill but I'm glad I heard the prime
sponsor introduce the the rationale
behind it it may surprise the prime
sponsor although it probably doesn't
surprise anybody who knows me well that
I actually uh was also very much opposed
to what we heard in media the behavior
of one party trying to interfere in the
other party's primary this last election
cycle and in fact I signed an online
petition I would happily add my name to
the list of names that the prime sponsor
mentioned
um but I don't think that this bill is
the right way to go about fixing that
particular type of problem I would be in
favor of making the behavior of a party
interfering in another party's primary
illegal but this bill doesn't go after
parties The Spill goes after voters
this bill goes specifically after
independent voters in a state that's not
just majority you know majority or
plurality independent voters but proudly
independent we are proudly independent
as a state I should have included in my
introduction that along with Tiani I was
one of the the founding members of New
Hampshire independent voters long before
I ran for office when she founded that
organization so when I see a bill that
I mean imagine as a voter that you're
used to same-day registration you're
used to all of this kind of small D
democracy we have and we're so proud of
in this state and that you show up and
to vote and I mean how many thousands of
people would be denied on primary day
um and again as was already stated by I
think it's worth reiterating the
deadline that's put forward in the bill
is before the candidates would be able
to even file
so how in the world would you be able to
choose which party to vote in
um one of the things that the prime
sponsor mentioned is a rationale of this
may be a really pervasive problem of of
parties interfering in each other's
primaries was the idea that if you have
a primary on one side and the turnout in
the primary is lower than what that
candidate gets in the general then that
looks suspicious but that's not actually
how that works
primary turnout is based on the horse
raciness of the primary this past
election cycle I'll just speak as a
Democrat the Democrats did not have very
interesting primaries we did not have
very interesting primaries for any of
the major offices and so our turnout was
quite low in the primary but that
doesn't mean that they were all voting
in the other party's primary it just
means they didn't bother to come out to
to vote in the primary whereas they were
motivated to vote in the general so just
because you have those low turnout
numbers in a and I think the prime
sponsor admitted that the gene sheehyun
race was a uncontested gubernatorial uh
primary election so you're going to have
low turnout it's uncontested that
doesn't mean that there's you know
Shenanigans afoot however I will say
because there have been it has been
evidence of shenanigans as is the case
with the the news reports we heard of
this last election cycle that those
Shenanigans are exactly why AI voters
become independent to begin with the the
idea that the two-party system is bitter
and divided and polarizing and we hate
each other and we're always like going
after each other it's why people want to
be Undeclared to begin with and so to
punish those people I don't think is
fair and I don't think it actually is
going to um get at the heart of the
problem
I will also say that the prime sponsor
might be gratified and perhaps less
angry at me if I'd tell him that when I
teach American government I always show
my students a clip from Mr Smith Goes to
Washington
but um with that I'll end it I'll take
questions from the committee
all right thank you
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee my name is Alvin C and I
represent Merrimack District 26 which is
a floaterial district with eight towns
in it I support
House Bill 101 I feel it's important for
voters in primary elections to associate
with a party to which they want to vote
in
a primary specifically for party
organization not for generals uh
accommodation of the public
if you're not interested in
participating in a party
then the primary is not a good place to
be
um
the main thing on the
uh primaries is
to replace the
um
so-called back room deals in party
conventions which previously were used
to select party candidates was always by
convention
and
there was a lot of
wheeling and dealing and everything else
that went on in in those back rooms and
that's what people wanted to get away
from so that's why we have state paid
for primary elections but it is still
um
to accommodate the individual parties as
to selecting their candidates to run in
the general election
anyone who
doesn't really want to associate with a
party
and the parties have statements of
principles or party platforms or however
you want to refer to it so that you can
decide for yourself whether that's a
group you want to associate with
regardless of who's who the candidates
are
then your your turn to participate is in
the general election
uh that's where everybody votes for no
matter who who the parties are including
minor parties and everything else
um
the um
as far as the bill itself is concerned I
do uh
suggests that you set it up if you were
going to pass this to accommodate
possible moving of the primaries
so that this doesn't become an
accidental
oversight when that happens
and also on line 27 where it says the
day before that should now say the day
after that day before
uh was in there to accommodate people
who were going to vote on primary day to
pick a ballot by choosing which party to
join
voting in the
on that ballot and then getting out of
that party so technically
uh by joining a party and taking a
ballot from that party
you are a member of the party so it's a
closed primary it's only people who are
registered in that party get the vote on
that ballot it's just that some people
take advantage of it and are able to
disassociate with the party immediately
after the election
I feel this uh Bill a lot to pass and I
wish to thank you and I'll take any
questions if there are any
thank you
questions from the committee
hello
um my name is Sam Bourne I'm 18 years
old I live in Rye and I was a graduate
of Portsmouth High School in 2022. I am
here to speak against the bill because I
believe fundamentally it will lower
voter turnout what you are doing and
what this bill is going to do is it will
increase it will add an increase in a
restriction making it harder for people
to vote in the primary I know there's a
line in the bill that says it's going to
educate voters to change their party
registration four months ahead of time
and my experience dealing with kids my
age that is incredibly unlikely right
now the youth voter turnover rate and
the general election for kids 18 to 19
is at 13
getting kids my age 18 19 College age to
turn out and vote in general elections
much less the primaries is almost
impossible if you want to have kids do
something four months ahead of time that
is not going to happen I mean two three
percent might switch their party
registration in time but the future of
this country youth voter turnout in the
primaries in is not going to happen and
this bill is going to decrease
registration in those primaries I think
we can all agree that less people voting
in elections is a bad thing for
democracy Now the second point is what
problem does this bill actually solve
now when presented the representative
gave two examples one case from 1996 and
one case from 2022 and both of those
cases the Democratic elections with Gene
shaquin in 1996 and Annie Custer in 2022
she ran unopposed the two Republican
primaries by contrast had two candidates
running for those nominations so it
makes a lot more sense that people
aren't going to vote in an election
where it's uncontested as opposed to an
election where there is a contest we can
look at that and you can actually see
and the primary results for Chris sununu
in 2022 he only got 100
000 votes in the primary election give
or take but in the general election he
won but more than 350 000 votes where
did those extra votes come from not from
just the Republican primaries but from
in because people did not vote in the
election because it was not contested
what is happening in the different
elections when people vote in primaries
or not in primaries is because
independent voters are choosing to come
and vote in the election where it is
contested people won't turn out if there
isn't a race to vote for so the case is
in the examples don't really hold and
you go to the third part
of the reason why the Democratic party
the national Democratic party is moving
to try to take away New Hampshire from
its presidential primary position one of
the reasons there's a law in place and
the Secretary of State can go into more
examples that New Hampshire has to be
the first Primary in the nation what is
going to happen in that case unlikely
hard to tell but one of the reasons that
they removed Iowa from the primary list
is because they had caucuses caucuses
mean that less people could turn out
this bill will be adding an increased
restriction meaning less people will be
able to turn out in the primaries when
that happens that's going to give the
national Democratic party one more
reason to help take the primary away
from New Hampshire by making it harder
by lowering voter turnout the Democrats
will have an increased incentive to take
the primary away from New Hampshire I
ask you not to give them one more reason
to strip New Hampshire of that right now
the final part is that this state is the
Live Free or Die State you should be
free to do what you want to do as Ronald
Reagan said government is not the
solution government is the problem this
is an increased bill this is another
bill that is putting another restriction
and another mandate forcing people to
what they can or cannot do as George
Washington said
political parties are potent engines by
which cunning and ambition and
unprincipled men will be able to subvert
the power of the people and usurp the
reins of government fundamentally this
bill will be decreasing the amount of
people who turn out in primaries it will
be decreasing people's rights to
exercise their political rights by
adding another step to it making it
harder and this will make this less of a
state I urge you to vote against this
bill because this is New Hampshire we
ought to be able to live free and die
and more government regulations and more
government restrictions based on two
examples from 1996 and 2022 there is not
a problem we do not need to be creating
more regulations to solve a problem
hurting democracy youth vote youth voter
turnout the potential New Hampshire
primaries and this state's long-term
thank you questions from the committee
representative Brennan
it's not a question but I just want to
say thank you for taking the time to
come out it's really important that you
turn out so thank you so much thank you
so that was really nice but this time is
are there any actual questions all right
thank you Mr chair Nate Graves for the
municipal Association since this is my
first time up here I'll introduce the
association for those of you who are new
Representatives we are a non-profit
nonpartisan uh voluntary membership
organization that currently represents
all 234 cities and towns in New
Hampshire
um we we do a number of things we
provide legal advice to cities and towns
we do trainings that's probably what
we're best known for we also come here
and advocate
on behalf of our members based on the
policy positions that they adopt during
our legislative policy conference which
occurs shortly before the general
election in each general election year
we are opposed to this uh piece of
legislation
we have a policy position to support
registration and voting processes that
are not unnecessarily complex or
burdensome either to voters or election
officials you know under our existing
system it allows unaffiliated voters to
decide which primary to vote in when
they show up on Election Day it's a
well-known system it's well established
we've had it in place for about 30 years
now and it runs very well
so we think that is the appropriate
policy position uh to keep at this time
and of course you've heard from another
uh many other speakers uh with with
other reasons as well I don't want to
take up too much of the committee's time
so I'm happy to take any questions that
you may have
thank you thank you questions
all right
secretary Scanlon were you going to
testify or just here as a resource
our uh four against it or just providing
information just providing information
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee I'm David Scanlon Secretary of
State uh here not taking a position on
the bill but offering some information
that might help you make a decision on
it as was mentioned in some prior
testimony there have been some courts
around the country that have opined on
this issue and what they say is that it
is the parties that get to decide who
participates in the Party primary
uh one of the reasons for that is to
keep a party in power from inflicting on
the other party legislation that might
determine who gets to participate in
that party's primary so that's uh that's
not happening in this case but you know
it it could under different
circumstances
representative Lane had mentioned that
that position established by the courts
is already in our Statute in RSA 659
colon 14 Roman numeral two and what that
statute says basically is that uh if the
party gives the Secretary of State
notice well in advance of the election
they can limit who participates uh in
their primary not only limit but they
could open it up so both parties the
Democratic party and the Republican
Party New Hampshire both allow
Undeclared voters to participate but
there's nothing to prevent the parties
from saying you know the Republican
Party could let Democrats participate
also and vice versa
uh or they could tighten it up and just
say we only want members of our party to
participate in our primary election
we also have a statute that says that on
the day before the filing period in June
opens up
supervisors of the checklist have to
hold a session
or
registered voters who belong to a
political party to be able to change
their party affiliation either to the
other party or to Undeclared status
and once that once that deadline goes by
they are locked in to that status and
will hold that through the primary
election
the other answer to a question that was
asked earlier about
what about a new voter that wants to
register within that window between the
filing period and the primary
if a new registration a brand new
registration is received by the
supervisors of the checklist in a town
or city that voter gets to declare their
party affiliation
on that registration and they are not
denied the right to vote because they're
registering within that window
uh that's all I have to say Mr chairman
I'd be happy to answer any questions
thank you Mr secretary we are five
minutes past the next hearing would it
be okay if members had questions that
they send them to you directly
representative Ankerberg can you send up
gonna need that up here
representative Kennedy
it's
so we had one sign in four one sign in
against
uh closes the public hearing on House
hey there we go we'll open the public
hearing on House Bill 116. welcome
thank you very much Mr chairman and
members of house election law this is
the first time I am testifying to
election law uh not as a member of the
committee so uh uh fourth term and uh
first term not on the committee of
election law so uh thank you again for
the opportunity to introduce House Bill
116. relative to fees and primary
petitions required for primary ballot
election access
the increase here might cause a bit of
sticker shock to you understandably so
but I do want to stress the increases
are only four campaigns running for the
United States Senate the United States
Congress and the office of Governor
within the two registered political
parties no other position sees an
increase it is a privilege to be placed
on the ballot for consideration by
irrespective political party in our
state primary elections statistically
candidates vying for the Democrat or
Republican nomination have a substantial
chance of winning their elections in our
state and the privilege of party-based
ballot access needs to be cognizant of
this fact
there will be no increase in this bill
for third party candidates to get on the
general election ballot nor do we limit
the ability of someone to run a writing
campaign if they are passionate about
declaring themselves a candidate but
they miss either the financial or
petition threshold set by this law you
may ask yourself why are we doing this
why are we submitting this legislation
as one ambivalent and torn Observer on
Twitter stated quite eloquently on the
one hand it limits ability to run for
high office on the other it limits
ability to run for high office
ten thousand dollars or twenty five
thousand petitions made by members of
their party for Statewide office is a
fair barrier for the privilege of ballot
access for the United States Senate and
governor and fairly so the filing fee or
number of signatures is cut in half to
run for a seat in Congress for someone
to be able to pay just a nominal fee or
submit a relative handful of petitions
and get their name printed on every
September primary ballot for their party
detract from the process and only adds
to voter confusion when they get to The
Ballot Box
many will hear from anywhere from three
to five candidates when they pay close
attention to who is running in their
respective party primaries for office
when they get to The Ballot Box they are
sometimes surprised to see over a dozen
names running for a high-level office
after watching every debate television
ad and getting mail that only listed
certain candidates to run successfully
Statewide or to be a member of Congress
for half our state one should be
required to demonstrate a requisite base
of support for their election by
instituting a reasonable barrier whether
it be Financial or petition based we
will require an individual to do one of
three things likely they will raise the
campaign contributions to pay for the
filing fee
compared to the cost of Television ads
mailers digital ads and other means of
communications not to mention the
Staffing and general operations of a
campaign ten thousand dollars for a
Statewide office and five thousand
dollars for a congressional run is a
fraction of what a competent and
competitive campaign is expected to
spend another option would be the
candidate self-funding part or all of
the filing fee in order to get on the
ballot as vain as we may consider some
candidates to be running for office is
not a vanity project and I highly doubt
anyone would be vain enough to spend
such a shum such a sum without putting
together an equally impressive campaign
operation that showcases a serious
candidate who is dedicated to the idea
of actually serving in this the office
that they're running for
thirdly the candidate has the ability to
collect signatures and have their team
collect signatures to get on the ballot
this is actually the option I would
recommend to a U.S Senate gubernatorial
or Congressional Campaign to pursue it
gives them a list of 25
000 plus Granite Staters in their party
willing to get them on the ballot and
would require them to build a campaign
operation Operation that stretches
throughout the state to some broad
appeal not just to party activists but
to rank and file members of their
respective parties that are not obsessed
with our political culture 24 7. such a
campaign and requirement for elected
office would force candidates to reach
out and appeal to voters not just in the
weeks before a primary election but in
the months before candidate filing
one-on-one getting signatures and
building a campaign team and
organization capable of such a task
I'm happy to take any questions and I
really do want to stress as with any
legislation that we consider and
typically the legislation that I like to
file uh the sponsorship team in my and I
are more than happy to have as many
conversation as it takes to work on this
legislation and get a bill or a version
of this bill across the Finish Line this
term so we can strengthen our primary
ballot access process and I believe make
our election process in New Hampshire
greater for it thank you for the time
thank you
representative boehm
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking the question
um
I have more concerned with the
presidential where people can file for
hardly anything but the problem is
wouldn't it be better than
you can spend this amount of money or
file for this amount of money and then
if you get a certain percentage of the
vote you can get money back what do you
think of that idea
I would I personally would be opposed to
it I actually think we heard testimony
in the previous uh Bill hearing uh
talking about the state funding these
elections and I actually think a great
solution to that is having the
candidates running for high office in
both parties essentially funding the
cost of printing ballots for the primary
elections which I think based on the
fiscal note this bill would in effect do
not knowing the exact specific numbers
on the cost for September primary ballot
printing but it does in my assessment it
should stay with the state to help cover
the cost of getting their name in every
town
representative Howard
thank you Mr chairman uh So speaking of
the fiscal note uh in the fiscal note it
States in the year 2024 and the fiscal
year for 2026 that the state revenue
would be 301 950 dollars
now that is a sum that is made up of
upwards of 40 candidates as you have
listed here uh seven of which uh running
for governor 14 running for Senate 19
running for congress is this something
that we can expect year after year and
if so this seems like a high number uh
to be saying that we should count on uh
for every single election
thank you representative for the
question uh I was not uh involved in
ols's construction of the fiscal note
with LBA
um I believe they based off their
numbers off Consulting with the
Secretary of State for historic trends
for candidates that do run for office on
both sides of the aisle
um and those were their projections for
2024 filing in 2026 filing we could very
well have 12 Republicans and 12
Democrats Run for the next U.S Senate
race in 2026 or the next open
gubernatorial race where there's an Open
Primary on both sides uh again I the the
fiscal note that's included wasn't part
of my piece of legislation it's attached
to the bill as what the Secretary of
State working with LBA advised would be
a likely or potential fiscal note uh
impact for the bill
follow up
thank you uh so for my follow-up
question uh the cost to run for
president uh for filing is a thousand
dollars now this would make it so that
the cost to run for governor is 10 times
that of what it would be to run for
president
do you have any thoughts on why that
number was chosen
uh the presidential primary on both
sides that a thousand dollars still sees
30 to 40 people even file uh for the
Republican and Democrat primary whether
there's an incumbent president or not
um I with this legislation it was
focused on the September primary I think
there is a bit of a different
distinction between the presidential
preference primary that we engage in
um for the state as first in the nation
primary and the state primary that
elects our state's elected officials
um so that's where I would draw the line
all right thank you thank you
oh I'm sorry I'm sorry I didn't see it
God representative Brennan thank you one
of the Prime bipartisan Arguments for
maintaining New Hampshire's first in the
nation status
um is that anyone can succeed in New
Hampshire anyone yeah so am I
understanding this proposal correctly to
say that one must have a war chest or a
complete campaign organization in order
to just file
one one in June or or whenever the
filing period is has to demonstrate the
ability uh if they're running for
governor U.S senate or congress that
they either have raised the funds
necessary to file to get on the ballot
or they have a campaign operation and
Grassroots support to support them
getting on the ballot as well it doesn't
limit who can do it we could still have
10 people running in a primary we could
still have 20 people running in a
primary they would just have to put the
effort in to get on to the privilege of
being on the ballot we keep the fees for
executive Council and state senate the
same uh and and currently it drafted in
the bill we actually zeroed out the
state representative fee
um and and I believe originally we
intended it to make it so that state
representative candidates would be
required to get five signatures from
their neighbors in order to get on the
ballot but I don't know if that actually
made it into the OLS draft so I'm not
going to commit to that version of the
bill at this at this time but that I was
I will say the original intent when we
were drafting the legislation but but
for the races of Governor U.S Senate and
Congress
um a reasonable threshold is put in
thank you further questions
representative Lane
um thank you Mr chair
um representative Sweeney can you
tell me how the the number 5000 and the
number 10 000 were chosen and then again
why the number for the petitions was
chosen so I can say for for the
Congressional races five thousand and uh
12 500 petitions we just cut in half the
ten thousand and twenty five thousand uh
and When approaching ten thousand and
twenty five thousand uh ten thousand is
currently the the maximum individual
donation a uh individual can give to a
gubernatorial campaign for the
pre-filing and then the prime uh primary
um period in the in state law so outside
of an individual giving them money
outside of them a candidate giving their
own campaign an unlimited amount of
money uh they can collect five thousand
in pre-filing and then five thousand for
the primary election so that's how we
came to that ten thousand number but
like I said again we're open to having
the conversation on the specific number
that we want to land out for this
legislation but logistically and then
once we had that set for governor it
made sense with the same number of
ballots being printed for U.S Senate
that we would make it 10 000 as well
thank you representative Sweeney thank
you
thank you very much Mr chair so my name
is Timothy Horrigan a reverend Stratford
County District six
um actually it's now District 10. even
though my old name takes as otherwise so
which is the towns of Durham town of
Durham
and I do some written testimony which I
wrote up well before I heard
representative I guess the member from
Manchester's testimony and um not that
it changed my mind in fact actually I
think I'm even more opposed to the bill
because he pointed out something that
escaped my notice or I didn't think much
about which was uh this doesn't
do anything to make it easier or harder
for people to run as third-party
candidates and I assume that probably
the intended effect of this
I guess not that I'm supposed to impune
motives but I'm inferring that the
effect of this bill if we pass would
probably be encouraged a lot more uh
insurgents to run outside the party
structure as third party candidates and
that probably has good points and bad
points but I'm personally not in favor
of it um so should I hand this around it
is I did submit to the website but I
don't really know where any of that
those files are going this year because
the last time we had that procedure you
could look them up on the website but
now they're just sort of
they're going somewhere but I don't know
where
sorry my Preamble is probably longer
than it needed to be but I'll just say
I've there's four main points
or maybe it's five but my first point is
simply
as we've already heard
hb116 raises a tax or fee
although they occasionally make
exceptions one of the core values of the
house Republican caucus is that no state
tax or fee should ever be raised for any
reason even by a small amount and even
on my side the Democratic uh we're
usually pretty reluctant to raise taxes
or fees if there isn't a good reason for
it and um I don't think there's a good
reason for it I don't think the reason
that I heard qualifies as a good reason
and it's not just a small amount as I
said ten thousand percent which is
um it does lower the State Rep fee from
two dollars to zero which that's a
pretty minuscule fee it doesn't make
much difference one way or the other it
does downshift
a few dollars of cost down to the town
clerk's office since unlike the other
offices we stay rep register at the Town
Hall not at the Secretary of State's
office but
um
thirdly and I think this is probably
born after the testimony we've already
heard they're high enough to discourage
lesser known candidates who've not
raised much money before the campaign
and this definitely would be a barrier
to entry for candidates of modest means
some of which have actually won in the
past not just in the primaries but
sometimes the general election
now we have had a few overcrowded
primaries with an article excessive
number of weaker candidates in the
ballots but those primaries you know
haven't resulted in Weak nominees you
know we've had a
strong nominees have come out of crowded
primaries uh we've had weak nominees
have come out of primaries with only two
or only one candidate
and anyway the huge proposed fee
increases aren't going to keep we'll
only keep poor fools from running they
won't dissuade Rich fools um
if HB 116 passes uh candidate should
also I think they've effectively denied
the alternative of gathering petitions
in lieu of paying a filing fee at least
for those uh
top of the ballot offices
and I guess we heard that they have to
collect a gubernatorial senatorial
candidates right now they only need to
bring in 200 they're going to have to
bring in 25
000.
and they said it like it's a good thing
that the party would now have a list of
000 people who pledged to a candidate
and that's
probably sometimes good but that also
discourages in my opinion uh
um Insurgent candidates you know like we
had
um
like any like governor sununu for the
first time has had a serious uh a couple
of serious opponents and they actually
got a lot less than uh ten thousand uh
25 000 votes the the more successful the
two got about ten thousand but it would
have been even harder for those
candidates to get their campaigns going
if they were like if they'd have to
submit 25 000 name sheltered for the
state committee for them to look
um so they could
and um congressional candidates 12 500
700 that's a twelve thousand five
hundred percent increase and that's
greatly uh increased the the cost of a
cost of Entry
and those are very large numbers
compared to the north people vote in the
primary like uh
147 501 voted in the Republican primary
in 2022 96 275 so that's like a pretty
high percentage of the people who
participate in these primaries and um
and so uh and finally we're talking
about the amount of money it doesn't
really raise such a different amount of
money
um even if no fringe candidates are
discouraged from running in 2024 if we
pass HB 116. it's only going to raise
about three hundred thousand dollars um
I think there's better places than the
state budget look for 300 000 and it was
uh
was represented that this would help
these candidates pay for the costs of
printing up the ballots and the work the
secretary of state does which is uh
significant but um
this money is earmarked for the general
fund so it's not earmarked for the
Secretary of State's office anyway so
this is an unnecessary
um unnecessary Bill and uh as with the
other one I would certainly urge you to
uh
your first opportunity there is
one small issue it bugs me which is kind
of mentioned in passing the bill which
talk about electing delegates the
Democratic party election delegates it
uh downtown conventions Republicans have
it on the ballot and I think
I think it would be a maybe maybe sounds
more small deep Democratic select among
the ballots but that that's a
substantial cost to the state like
because there's lots of write-ins a lot
of people lots of uh candidates people
don't know so it might it might actually
be more fair to for the Republicans to
also elect them the same way at the
local Town conventions but that's uh
that's a minor point but anyway so
I'd be happy to take any questions if
anyone has has anyone
thank you
questions
all right thank you representative yes I
will I'd also miss like every year I'd
like to get a two dollar bill from the
bank so I always enjoy bringing in a two
dollar bill to the town clerk's office
and I wouldn't have to I wouldn't be
able to do that anymore but all right
foreign
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee I'm rise in opposition to
house bill 116. this bill drastically
increases the fees for running for the
top three offices in New Hampshire this
is not an increase that matches
inflation and it appears to designed to
favor Rich candidates that may not be
the intent but it gives that appearance
a hundred times increased I feel is
unreasonable
the alternative filing by nomination
papers now will require a large team of
petitioners to gather this large number
a huge number of petitions uh within the
approximately three-month time period
that it's needed to get them in
this also puts a huge burden on local
supervisors the checklist because they
are the ones that have to verify such
petitions
uh
this bill also does not present a good
optic for New Hampshire by making it
more difficult for candidates to get on
the ballot and thus reducing the choices
for voters
removing the two dollar fee from state
representative candidates does not
remove any significant barrier to
becoming a candidate and deprives the
local community of even covering
photocopy costs for registering the
candidate
I urge is committee to itl this bill
thank you and I'll take any questions if
there are any
thank you questions
thank you uh I am Sam boy and I spoke
previously Ira or stand today in
opposition to this bill for the basic
and fundamental reasons that this is
about ballot access there the reason
stated for adding the fees is that the
problem is that there are too many names
and it's a lot of names for people to
look at and we print a lot of paper and
the terms of there's a lot of names I
believe if you are going to go and
you're going to vote for the governor or
senate or presidential race you will
have done your research ahead of time
and you can find a name and dare you
have to look at 20 names you will be
able to select the candidate that you
wanted the odds that somebody will be
making a decision in The Ballot Box
having Google 20 names who they have
never heard of is an unlikely one and on
the second point of the cost of printing
paper there are more effective ways to
either cut funding from other measures
or raise small amounts of taxes if
printing paper is truly the reason for
the fee increases
at a fundamental level putting up
another barrier to obstructing people's
ability to get on the ballot is not a
good one for the health or the viability
long term of our democracy if somebody
wants to run for their ego or they want
to run because they are vain so what
they get on the ballot that's okay but
if somebody legitimately wants to have
an upstart Insurgency candidacy and they
don't have the funding or the support I
believe in America and in New Hampshire
they ought to have a shot to be able to
do that there are no harms to us as
Citizens representatives of this state
that there will be another name on the
ballot and that we will have to spend a
tenth of a penny printing their name in
ink I urge you to vote against this bill
because in a because again going back to
the Ronald Raven quote government is not
the problem government is this
government is not the solution
government is the problem there does not
need to be an added or increased
restriction in preventing people's
access to the ballot and their ability
to vote thank you
thank you questions
Stephen Born Ryan Hampshire thank you
very much I'm opposed to this bill for a
number of reasons and believe it or not
there is one part that I actually do
like that I'll tell you about
um we as speaking for Undeclared voters
I'm not nominated to speak for all of
them but as one we would like more
choices this would give us less choices
also if you have the same sort of people
running all the time you get the same
ideas
all right having easy ballot access
there's a lot of people that run they're
one-trick ponies they want to give one
idea or platform to talk about this
would make that harder so we wouldn't
get maybe those ingenious ideas the
things that really none of us have
thought about yet but really move the
needle so this would limit the health
all right it's how you um Evolution
fails when you do these kind of things
um the second problem is that the smarts
of this vote this measure
equated seriousness to money
and I think that's a misnomer and it's a
problem one of the biggest things
driving some of the dysfunction and the
way are we manage our Republic is all of
the money now I happen to be an
Undeclared voter so I get all this
lovely mail from both sides it's gross
how much money from out of state pours
in to tell me what I should be doing so
money's not good also the other speaker
mentioned
you know some of the people the most
money are the scariest they may not be
the people that we want on our ballot
maybe these people with some ideas
on to petitions
um who here has gone out and collected a
bunch of petitions
to run for office am I the only one here
that's gone out and done that and
collected petitions to get on the ballot
okay
um
as the one person's done it probably is
learned it's not that easy
okay it's pretty difficult you'd be
amazed people don't even know where they
vote
you have to get in the people do you
know where the current political climate
do you know how receptive people are to
talk to you and do that it's not easy
all right this is a really high barrier
it can be done groups have come in and
collected tons of signatures in New
Hampshire you know how they do it
outside money
they bring in a ton of people they pay
people and they get it done it's not New
Hampshire people going out and
collecting seniors just for New
Hampshire people it's other people's
money putting candidates to tell us what
we're going to do
um
it and anybody we have one person that
knows the process of collecting a
signature petition not only do you have
to convince the person to sign this
petition explain this to them
then you have to especially if you have
to organize them
all right by where they voted guess how
many people know their Ward number not
many
okay they know where to go but they
don't know the ward number
you have to organize them by that then
you have to go to the town hall the city
clerk and find the supervisor the
checklist two supervisors the checklist
have to look at each petition
okay and sign it off together so you
have created a huge amount of work for
the sex supervisors the checklist now if
you hold that position you know that
it's not a very highly paid position
it's volunteer so you're creating a huge
amount of work for that
um just out of curiosity if you wanted
to get an independent party on the
ballot in New Hampshire anyone I want to
take a guess of How High that stack of
petitions need to be
to get an independent party on through
the petition process
no how about 10 feet
you stacked all those petitions on top
that would be now
there is actually one good thing that
could come out of this bill from my
perspective is that if this bill does
pass
um it could lead to The Disappearance of
the Republican and Democratic party and
I would support that
do you know why
because to maintain your status of the
party
the Republican and Democratic party need
to get on at least one candidate on a
Statewide
all right office and there's only three
of them the two Senate seats and the
governor's office and every you know
there's only you know out of the six
years there's one year where there's
only the governor that runs so let's say
the Republicans are Democrats can't come
up with somebody to Fork up the twenty
five thousand dollars and come up this
in they don't have a candidate on the
ballot guess what happens to that party
next year
bye bye and then you're with me
collecting 10 feet of petitions or
trying to get somebody to run for one of
those office in the next election cycle
to try to get them up ready so I just
thought I should point that out to you
thank you questions from the committee
thank you Mr chair and each crazy for
the municipal Association again uh our
only real interest in this bill is the
fact that currently when you file for
State Rep the two dollars that your
filing fee is is kept at the Town level
so we vigorously defend all revenue
streams from the town
um so we would suggest that if the
committee would like to pass this bill
that they adopt an amendment that would
preserve that two dollar fee going and
being kept in the town I've spoken with
the prime sponsor he would not object to
that Amendment thank you
representative bankerberg could just
okay
and signing in we have one in favor four
against and that closes the public
hearing on House Bill 116.
so the committee probably wants to know
what to expect now
we're likely to exec both of these bills
next Tuesday
and the rest of the day will be as many
bills as I can Cobble together so it
should be a fairly
full day we'll we'll start at 10 and get
through as many bills as we can and exec
at the end
anything else
yeah
what do you mean like when they put
I don't know my first time since we